[Music]
have you been to Amsterdam I have okay
that's all I wanted to
know no I uh it's one of those countries
where they pretty much all speak English
and uh and I found myself still over
enunciating and uh when we were in the
in the
cab I said could you take us to the
train station
and then I was like that wasn't
necessary and then in my head I realized
I sounded kind of like one of those um
uh learn a new language tapes so before
I said
anything anytime I started laughing
beforehand because I knew I was going to
sound like I was trying to learn a new
language you know like could you point
me in the direction of the
apothecary
I'm like that's weird I've never said
the word
Apothecary until I was in Amsterdam yeah
you learn like bizarre small talk from
Rosetta Stone yeah rainy and windy today
wouldn't you
say you're either like a serial killer
or someone just getting their legs with
a new tongue yeah getting their legs
with a new
tongue that sounds
disgusting
I'm picturing a man with two tongues for
legs I'm picturing putting legs on the
tongue hang on just got my leg with my
Tong
yeah you're the most
fun we have time for one more
[Applause]
[Music]
hour